[Music]
20,000 years ago the earth was a frigid
landscape where woolly mammoths roamed
huge ice sheets several thousand meters
thick encased parts of North America
Asia and Europe we commonly know it as
the Ice Age but geologists call it the
last glacial maximum that's because it's
the most recent time that ice reached
such a huge extent and ice age is an
informal term without a single
agreed-upon definition over the last
million years there have actually been
about 10 different glacial Maxima
throughout Earth's history climate has
varied greatly for hundreds of millions
of years the planet had no polar ice
caps without this ice the sea-level was
70 metres higher at the other extreme
about 700 million years ago earth became
almost entirely covered in ice during an
event known as snowball earth so what
causes these massive swings in the
planet's climate one of the main drivers
is atmospheric carbon dioxide a
greenhouse gas that traps heat natural
processes such as volcanism chemical
weathering of rocks and the burial of
organic matter can cause huge changes in
carbon dioxide when they continue for
millions of years over the past million
years carbon dioxide has been relatively
low and repeated glacial Maxima have
been caused by cycles and Earth's
movement around the Sun as Earth rotates
it wobbles on its axis and its tilt
changes altering the amount of sunlight
that strikes different parts of its
surface these wobbles combined with the
planets elliptical orbit caused summer
temperatures to vary depending on
whether the summer solstice happens when
earth is closer or farther from the Sun
approximately every 100,000 years these
factors align to create dramatically
colder conditions that last for
millennia cool summers that aren't warm
enough to melt the preceding winters
snow
allow ice to accumulate year after year
these ice sheets produce additional
cooling by reflecting more solar energy
back into space simultaneously cooler
conditions transfer carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere into the ocean causing
even more cooling and glacier expansion
about 20,000 years ago these trends
reversed when changes in Earth's orbit
increased summer sunshine over the giant
ice sheets and they began to melt the
sea level rose 130 meters and carbon
dioxide was released from the ocean back
into the atmosphere by analyzing pollen
and marine fossils geologists can tell
that temperatures peaked about 6,000
years ago before another shift in
Earth's orbit caused renewed cooling so
what's coming next
based on the repeated natural cycle seen
in the climate record we'd normally
expect the earth to continue a trend of
gradual cooling for the next few
thousand years however this cooling
abruptly reversed about a hundred and
fifty years ago why carbon dioxide
levels in the atmosphere have been
rising since the 19th century when
fossil fuel use increased we know that
from studying air bubbles trapped in
Antarctic ice this surge in carbon
dioxide also coincides with a global
temperature increase of nearly 1 degrees
Celsius ice cores and atmospheric
monitoring stations show us that carbon
dioxide levels are rising faster and to
higher levels than at any point in the
last 800,000 years computer models
forecast another 1 to 4 degrees Celsius
of warming by 2100 depending on how much
additional fossil fuel will we burn what
does that mean for the ice currently on
Greenland and Antarctica past climate
changes suggest that even a small
warming shift can begin a process of ice
melt that continues for thousands of
years by the end of this century ice
melt is expected to raise the sea level
by 30 to 100 centimeters enough to
impact many coastal cities and island
nations if a 4 degrees Celsius warming
persisted for several millennia the sea
level could rise by as much as 10 meters
by studying past climates scientists
learn more about what drives the shifts
in ice that have shaped our planet for
millions of years research suggests that
by taking action now
to reduce carbon dioxide emissions
quickly we still have the opportunity to
curb ice loss and save our coastal
communities if you're a student watching
this now we have a question for you do
you ever feel like you're too young to
have any
you'll impact on climate change if so we
disagree all these students in our Ted
ed clubs program are speaking up and
taking action to fight for a healthy
habitable planet and maybe the next
great idea or well chosen word that will
change the world or change someone's
mind will be yours
visit Edie ted.com slash clubs to join
our student voice program and share your
passion on the ted platform
[Music]